nous sommes ici devant une
œuvre exceptionnelle voir une estimable
pour l'histoire de la Réunion histoire
de l'art mais aussi l'histoire en
général puisqu'elle a été peinte vers
1803 par Jean-Joseph battu de Rosemont
et cette touche très sensible qu'il
apporte à 16 œuvres qu'il a
majoritairement exécuté à l'île de la
Réunion
est magnifique dans ce tableau qui était
jusqu'à ce jour inconnu de tableau
s'intitule vu de l'habitation de
beaufond quartier Saint-Benoît à l'île
Bourbon
aujourd'hui
elle est exposée au musée le 11e
puisqu'il s'agit
de la représentation la plus ancienne
d'un paysage et d'une scène animée de la
vie réunionnaise alors si on s'intéresse
maintenant à l'oeuvre picturale
graphique rendu
les mains du maître on se rend compte
qu'elle contient qu'elle présente
beaucoup de personnages que que battu a
déjà peint et ou représentait dans ces
œuvres si on regarde attentivement
l'oeuvre on et pour ceux qui connaissent
les aquarelles de pâture notamment les
ruption du volcan en 1812 il a déjà
représenté
son esclave attitré on remarque ce
personnage qui fume sa pipe
tranquillement plutôt libre on remarque
aussi les nombres chefs cabris
boeuf on remarque aussi ce couple qu'on
peut soupçonner pour la fille pour la le
personnage féminin être la fille de
patchu avec son futur mari et en groupe
de personnages et donc ces cinq
personnages
plutôt
aux allures élégantes et noble qui sont
en train de discuter d'une nouvelle
aujourd'hui les hommes de Jean-Joseph
statut de Rosemont sont évidemment
rarissimes et
la collection que concerne le musée et
les archives départementales
je crois qu'on tient une vingtaine
d'heures surtout des dessins des
aquarelles donc plutôt de petits formats
et une ou deux gravures que passion a
réalisé à la fin de sa ville lorsqu'il
est rentré à Paris voilà ce qu'on peut
dire
très brièvement sur cette œuvre encore
une fois exceptionnelle pour
qui n'est pas d'un grand format mais qui
a un véritable tableau et
rare aperçu patrimonial
de notre histoire qui est sans cesse
découverte